how you needed egress was really get
nervous no I don't do that we're
supposed to be don't want to nervous
okay all right ground yourself grab
something yeah there you go
that helps okay Omari four other actors
watching your career right now you're
making it look very easy which I know
you've talked about how it hasn't been
for you um but you know you're you're in
shock caller you're on power and you
have all these projects going let's talk
about the hypothetical la friend that a
lot of us have was a talented
hard-working actor what they can't get
in a room because they're not
represented by the right HSN what's your
advice for that person great way to
start an interview first of all it's
interesting because tonight for example
I am inviting friends who got off the
Hollywood dream bus with me who never
necessarily were able to execute
anything you know it's interesting
they'll be at the screening tonight for
this film and and it's one of those
things where we don't have the same
level of in common conversation that we
want to add because life has happened
for me differently and I had to really
check in with myself in terms of the
team personality and me thought that and
I've always been a part of sports that
everybody I get off the dream bus with
me and what I mean by that is around the
same month that you get off to dream but
then you come to LA or New York to make
things happen you get a collective of
friends and y'all all started to run
audition circuit and slowly certain
people's pace slows down and others keep
going and my big thing always to those
people I'm inviting the night and to as
you said those that are aspiring actors
my wisdom and advice was always first
and foremost if you can wake up without
wanting to do this you have one morning
where you wake up and go I don't really
want to do this I would say get out
because it's way too difficult
somebody could ask me are there moments
of that being defined as being
discouraged and I will go know
everybody's discouraged everybody calls
home and goes I don't know if you know I
should
become a rocket scientist if I should as
a woman continue in this world of men
and corporate spectrums or law or
medicine or what have you people will
all get discouraged including myself and
asking mom and dad if I should come back
home very early in my journey out here
but I think in terms of the
representation part I decided to not and
this is really my wisdom to them to not
really worry about it
my thought was you know if it's looked
if it looked like it was easier for me
than it was was because I really pressed
hard at the craft the work acting
classes making sure that I was in
martial arts if I could add that to the
repertoire box or the box of tools that
I could dig into if I needed to work on
the piano because one day I could play a
character where I played the piano just
work on the craft and don't necessarily
worry about the representation they will
it'll find you the right a gentle find
your the right manager the right but now
am i struggling in terms of wanting even
bigger out of my career well there's
people not where I'm at going you look
like you made it I don't know what make
it is you know I'm satisfied I'm so
humbled and thankful to God that I'm
where I'm at but it's always more and so
if you focus on the more being attained
by you making sure that you do more for
yourself then I don't necessarily think
the representation should matter
again they definitely will always find
you thank you oh thank you
you